[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment or weekly anime news cast
the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments if
you're new to the channel this is a
weekly newscast that we have here at
anime out for when we catch you up on
all the latest anime and manga news
now usually we publish these videos on
Tuesdays but because we got so many
interesting news coming out of Anime
Expo which was happening this weekend we
decided to publish this video right now
on Monday before we get into it I want
to give a quick thank you to all of you
for supporting the channel we've been
growing at an amazing rate lately we are
over 30,000 subscribers which is an
amazing accomplishment thank you so much
to mark the occasion just this morning I
received this awesome bit of fan art
from potenti this is our little anime
logo dude dressed up in some code geass
gear and it's absolutely amazing thank
you so much at entry I will link to
hitachi deviant art account in the
description be sure to check it out the
other quick announcement is that in
honor of the 30k subscribers milestone
we are organizing a anime uproar
official flag contest over on our
discord server if you want to help
create an official flag for anime uproar
you can join our discord server and over
there you can enter the contest
the winning entry is going to be
showcased here on the channel we're
going to shout you out and of course
link to your Twitter or deviantART
account thank you so much to Nana for
helping to organize this and we got a
bunch of other stuff coming up down the
line including writing contests where
we're going to be having entries
competing for the best idea for a new
manga or anime so be sure like I said if
you want to enter that join the discord
server like in the description and thank
you to silver elf for taking the lead on
the writing contest and now into the big
news
crunchyroll and other sources are
reporting that attack on titan season 3
is scheduled for as early as spring 2018
the official Funimation anime expo
presentation listed attack on titan
season 3 as coming in spring 2018 which
would be amazing obviously a few weeks
ago when we got the news that attack on
titan season 3 would be coming already
in 2018 we were all so happy ecstatic
and now it could be that it's coming as
early as spring 2018 however this
information is still tentative I checked
the official Japanese website for attack
on Titan and there is still no specific
information about spring 2018 however I
definitely hope that this is the case
and let me know down in the comments if
you're excited and if you happen to be a
fan of our attack on titan videos on
twitter we've started posting the
thumbnail for our next attack on titan
video before we draw up the videos so if
you want to be the first to know which
attack on titan video is going to be
dropping next and what the thumbnail is
going to look like be sure to follow us
on twitter the link is in the
description also at Anime Expo a brand
new trailer for fully cooley seasons 2
and 3 has been released at the con I
would like to show you the trailer here
but I can because YouTube has been
taking them down all over the place
however I will leave a link in the
description to a third party website
that I have nothing to do with if you
want to check out the trailer for
yourself I'm a huge fan of fooly cooly
and my first impressions are definitely
positive I love the music by the pillows
brings back so many memories
the animation looks updated it looks
improved however it still captures the
genuine style of fooly cooly
you can still definitely see that it's
the same show and of course we got to
see how to go best girl Haruko so I was
definitely excited to see this trailer I
loved it and I'm really excited for
seasons two and three and for fans of
food wars last week we got the
announcement that food Wars
season 3 is going to be released in fall
of 2018 this new season is going to be
called food Wars the third plate and it
is going to follow the battle against
the Council of 10 let me know if you're
a food Wars fan if you're excited for
season 3 down below last week we learned
that the seven deadly sins anime and
manga franchise is going to be getting
its own ps4 game set to come out
sometime in early 2018 now for fans of
the seven deadly sins anime the news
that they're really looking for is seven
deadly sins
season two however we still don't have
season
News but I was wondering do you think
that announcing a ps4 game is actually a
good sign for seven deadly sin season
two now obviously they're investing a
lot of money to put this game out they
know that there is an audience there is
profit to be made so I'm hoping that
this means that a seven deadly sins
season two is more likely also last week
we got a brand new PV for the second
half of the my hero academia second
season and this PV was really really
interesting now you guys know that
unlike goes in I myself am NOT a big fan
of Deku at all but I really do like
other characters like Todoroki and some
of the villains and thankfully in this
trailer we got to see a lot of the
villains we got to see shigaraki kudo
get a stain and a bunch of other cool
stuff so this PV definitely got me
excited to watch the second half of the
season because I know that the villains
are going to be playing a much more
important role and speaking of which I
want to thank you guys really quickly
for all the support we've been getting
on our every villain my hero academia
video as well as our every quirk class
1-a my hero academia video and stain
explained video it's been amazing thank
you so much more videos are coming soon
sometime later this week so stay tuned
our boy nuktuk who released a sarcastic
anime trailer for attack on titan on his
channel last week and it was absolutely
hilarious
now of course goes on and I are both
massive fans of Dagon tyne and so is
nuts but this video is just so funny we
watched it and laughed out loud the
whole time be sure to check it out link
in the description speaking of our
friends our fellow Red Cafe member
Mackinac made a video yesterday where he
said that he will be taking a short
break from YouTube because he has to do
a bunch of other stuff in his life he
has a band and a job and all that kind
of stuff however he will be back
hopefully soon and guess what guys he
reached over 2,000 subscribers on his
channel and he promised that if he
reached 2,000 subscribers he would
cosplay as RAM from re0 so if you want
to see a grown man with a mustache
cosplaying as RAM
be sure to check out his channel and
subscribe to him I will leave the link
description show them some love Lak
uploaded a new cover on his channel
recently and this time it was a cover of
the second season opening all attack on
titan now i've been saying from the very
beginning that I really like this
opening I like the song and the opening
a lot of people were complaining and
saying it's not as good as the first
season but I loved it from the get-go
and this cover by Pelle K is absolutely
brilliant he did a phenomenal job be
sure to check it out and my favorite a
MV for this week is an a key to the
Exile and we called by myself by
Warlocks a.m. V's right in time for the
official fun dimension release of the
english dubbed version of akut on the
exiled warlocks and V's does a great job
with this one as he usually does the
quality is brilliant it is a very well
done AMV and I'm sure fans of oculi
exile thank code geass in general will
definitely like it and that is it for
this week guys by the way we're going to
try to do a regular twitch stream every
Saturday at 8 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
we play party games with you guys and
just hang out it's a very chill
atmosphere because our twitch account is
much smaller than our YouTube account so
if that is something you are interested
in be sure to follow us on Twitch anime
uproar and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]